بلده بخموت في منطقه دونيات شرقيه
اوكرانيا والتي كانت ذات يوم موطنا لاكثر
من 70 الف شخص هي اسخن جبهه للقتال منذ
عده اشهر بين القوات الاوكرانيه والقوه
الروسيه ومعها
احدث فصولها بعد اشهر من تقدم والسيطره
شبه كليه روسيه معلنه اعلان الجيش
الاوكراني تمكنه لاول مره من استعاده اراد
في شمال المدينه وجنوبها ومن كسر الطوق
شبه المحكم عليها نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني قالت ان قوات بلادها حررت نحو
20 كيلومترا مربعا شمال وجنوب ضواحي بخموت
وتظهر باللون الازرق ودفعت القوات الروسيه
نحو الشمال والجنوب الغربي لعده كيلومترات
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه تحدثت بدورها عن
نجاح تكتيكيا اوكراني في الايام الاربعه
الاخيره واشارت الى ان الجيش الاوكراني
يعمل حاليا على كبح الهجوم الروسي عند خط
قناه سيفسكي وتحويل الممر المائي الى جزء
من شريط دفاعي عميق حول مدينه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان وحداتها الهجوميه
تواصل تقدمها في الاحياء الغربيه من بخموت
وان قوات الانزال المحموله جوا سيطرت على
مواقع دفاعيه جيده خلال هجوم لها واشار
مالك مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه
في تسجيل صوتي الى تقدم وحداته 200 متر
واحتلالها نحو 113 الف متر مربع لكن قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه اولكسندرسكي وصف
بلده بخموت المحاصره بانها من صياده فئران
للقوات الروسيه من خلال الدفاع الناشط
لقواته وشنها هجمات مضاده ويشير محللون
عسكريون الى ان ما يحدث في بخموت محاوله
اوكرانيه لتثبيت القوات الروسيه في
المدينه واجبارها على البقاء في نقطه
معينه بينما تختار القوات الاوكرانيه
العديد من المناطق لمهاجمتها وتشكل نتائج
الوضع على جبهه بخموت اهميه لكل الطرفين
هبسطت السيطره الروسيه عليها تهديد لمدن
رئيسيه اخرى مجاوره ابرزها سلوفيا
مركز العمليات الاوكرانيه وخسارتها
تدريجيا واستعاده الاوكرانيين لها او
لاجزاء منها انتكاسه عسكريه وسياسيه
لروسيا ولمجموعه فاغنر ودعم معنوي لكييف
وهي تخوض ما تسميه هجوما مضاده لاستعاده
اراضيها